[Musique]
plastiques batteries électriques eaux
usées déchets ménagers le marché du
recyclage est très prometteur et c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour la planète jean
todt frérot besoin de vivre ça va très
bien pdg théorie installez-vous en
revanche ce qui est pas une bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'en france seulement
28% du plastique et recycler c'est trop
peu évidemment pourquoi est ce que est
ce qu'on y est pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
à la traîne parce qu'on est à la traîne
quand on se compare par rapport aux
européens oui parce que dans l'eau au
niveau mondial c'est moins de 10% mène
alors ce 28% il est pas suffisant mais
il progresse puisque c'était 24 % il ya
deux ans la raison pour laquelle on est
seulement 28 % c'est que on n'a pas
encore assez d'utilisateurs de plastique
recyclé pour fabriquer de nouveaux
objets en plastique
parce que les industriels du plastique
avaient leurs propres mécanismes de
production et ils rechignent un petit
peu il refuse un petit peu utilisé du
plastique recyclé ils sont peut-être
trop lent on va dire mais ça progresse
et de la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'en 2021
justement on va encore monter et l'année
prochaine encore davantage oui parce que
le plastique recyclé ça peut coûter
encore plus cher que la résine vierge
même si avec le prix des hydrocarbures
qui montent beaucoup ça va sans doute un
moment s'inverser mais ça monte
progressivement c'est vrai que les 28 %
on en collecte et en on trie plus que
28% meoli a multiplié par quatre depuis
cinq ans ces unités de recyclage du
plastique mais nous n'avons pas encore
assez de clients pour acheter ces
pratiques recycler ça va venir très
progressivement bafin je pense que dans
quelques années on sera 40 % la france
est engagée à tendre vers 100 % c'est
pas 40% c'est 100 % de plastique recyclé
en 2025 est-ce que c'est mission
impossible parce que l'objectif fut
qu'un expert n'a pas l'air très très
contraignant c'est une ambition les gens
sont bien évidemment et donc c'est comme
ça vive aux lois mais pourtant recyclé
100% il faudrait que
peut-être inciter voire peut-être
contraindre ceux qui utilisent du
plastique tous les ans à en mettre de
plus en plus donc il faudrait un cadre
réglementaire plus strict sur l'usagé du
plastique recyclé recyclés par les
industriels souvent pérou incitatif un
voisin non mais les deux fonctionnent
vous savez si si le plastique recyclé
coûte moins cher qu'une petite vierge si
pollué coûte plus cher que ne pas
polluer c'est à ciné live voir les
acteurs tout de suite bien évidemment
ces lignes il est je pense que
progressivement c'est ça qui va venir se
mettre en place vous produisez des
cartes sim puisqu'on parle de recyclage
du plastique et cartes sim à base de
plastique recyclé notamment issus des
réfrigérateurs on en produit quatre
milliards et demi dans le monde des
cartes sim que le business il est énorme
oui on en voit rarement des cas la
première quatre cycles et et donc cela
aussi c'est un set à démarrage c'est un
début le plastique de les réfrigérateurs
effectivement c'est le même plastique
qu'on utilise dans les dents les cartes
u sim et donc c'est pour ça que c'est de
la com' recycle là aussi on est au début
d'un processus
mais effectivement
dans quelques années ça sera un milliard
puis 2 milliards et un jour on arrivera
au 4 milliards de cartes sim chaque
année avec du plastique recyclé et pas
seulement du plastique d'ailleurs mais
également d'autres produits antoine
frérot est ce que vous consommez des
yaourts ça m'arrive bon vous me voyez
venir en consomme 130 daoud par an et
par habitant et la plupart des pôles
yaourt ne sont jamais recyclé le plus
souvent ils sont incinérés ou enfouis
est-ce que c'est trop complexe à
recycler ou est-ce que économique on
sait pas assez rentable pour les
recycleurs de le faire vous savez qu'il
existe de nombreuses sortes de
plastiques
plus d'une centaine
cinq types de plastiques représentent
80% du plaisir qu'on utilise les pots de
yaourt c'est pas dans les cinq c'est du
pvc est donc aujourd'hui on sait
techniquement très mal le recycler et
c'est pourquoi ça peut paraître bizarre
parce que le plastique des bouteilles
d'eau on sait très bien de recycler ceux
des bouteilles de shampoing ceux des
pare chocs de voitures par exemple mais
pas les payeurs mais pas les podiums
parce que rohr pourquoi parce que de
denrées diané des molécules qui sont
très complexes
à recycler afin de refabriquer une
résine plastique qui donne les mêmes
qualités techniques donc on bute sur une
contrainte technique pour la star oui on
parle de la voiture électrique antoine
frérot pourquoi parce qu'avec l'essor
des ventes de voitures faudra avant
quelques années 2030 peut être un avant
recycler des millions de batteries écrit
millions dans le monde évidemment
sachant qu'une batterie doit être retiré
d'un véhicule quand elle perd 30% en
gros de sa performance la bonne nouvelle
c'est que 90% de ces matériaux d'une
batterie qu'on sait on peut
théoriquement on peut théoriquement les
recycler nous avons peu dont on le fait
déjà figurez-vous pour les peu de
batterie électrique qui arrivent en fin
de vie puisque n'a pas beaucoup
aujourd'hui encore on sait leur cité et
dans une usine de veolia en moselle on
recycle plus de 90 97% de la batterie
non seulement la coque le métal et
plastique mais on sait également recyclé
dedans ddd métaux rares et des matières
rares allez je vous ai apporté des
choses dans ce petit flacon
et du carbonate de lithium ouais pur à
99 9% c'est exactement ce dit yom
qu'utilisent les fabricants de batteries
neuves et bien ri ciel qui est extrait à
l'autre bout du monde oui d'habitude des
mines en chine lou chili celle là elle
est extrait des batteries usagées les
premières dans d'autres villes de dieuze
en moselle donc on sait écrire le
lithium comme le cobalt comme le zinc
comme les autres matières donc c'est une
seconde vie donc à tous ces matériaux
voilà ce qui est évidemment très bon
pour l'environnement pour la planète oui
parce que les batteries au plus sait
c'est un peu lourd et c'est un déchet
toxique une batterie qu'on peut pas la
laisser traîner dans la nature comme ça
c'est très polluant si on veut stopper
la rareté de ces matières premières ou
la surexploitation des sous sols il est
important de donner aux déchets une
deuxième billet d'être informé en
ressources à celle en lithium cobalt
cuivre qui donne une batterie vous
trouvez tous à vos chères aujourd'hui en
plus ça oui le progrès et le vieil homme
et le zinc mais surtout le cobalt et le
lithium absolument d'ailleurs vous
ambitionnez être le fra champion
européen là-dessus du recyclage de la
batterie électrique voit plein d'humour
il ya beaucoup de compétiteurs là dessus
qu'ils se positionnent en a encore à
marcher aujourd'hui mais il est en
devenir comme c'est ta ma su revenir il
va y avoir de plus en plus et c'est pour
ça aussi que veolia s'est associé avec
deux partenaires se lever pour la chimie
fine et la dernier stade de purification
de ces deux de ces métaux récupérés et
renault parce que renault sera un grand
utilisateur en fabriquant des batteries
pour ses véhicules électriques de ces
matériaux un petit mot de l'eau face à
la rareté de l'eau et ce qui vaut mieux
dessaler l'eau de mer ou recycler les
eaux usées il faut mieux recycler les
eaux usées pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que pourquoi pas les deux mon
général alors on peut faire les deux
mais quand on fait quand on réutilise
les eaux usées
normalement on en a assez puisque tout
ce qui a été utilisée peut être recyclée
à plus d'une raison c'est qu'ils aient
pas de limère partout non plus et donc
y'a pas d'autres baer partout et surtout
moins chère de recycler les eaux usées
aujourd'hui des eaux usées sont pas
recyclées non très peu 4% dans le monde
1 % seulement en france mais vous avez
des pays qui n'ont pas assez d'eau
potable nos propres naturel bodonon
salée en israël par exemple au round 6
90% des eaux usées mais même en espagne
un en or aux tic le 18 % en france pas
assez parce que euh on avait encore
suffisamment doute mais de plus en plus
on va y venir et pas seulement pour des
usages d'eric à sion ou d'arrosage mais
également pour des besoins
d'alimentation des populations ou même
en cas de besoin d'eau ultra purs pour
des usines qui nécessiterait une pureté
particulière antoine frérot en matière
de déchets ya beaucoup d'innovations
aujourd'hui on sait transformer nos
déchets ménagers en énergie quarante
mille habitants de l'île sont chauffés
par l'énergie produite par incinération
de leurs déchets et là on se dit qu'on
est totalement dans l'économie
circulaire on est au début de quelque
chose là aussi comment ça marche alors
on est déjà bien avancé cette idée de
valorisation énergétique des déchets les
déchets plutôt que rien en faire autant
en fabriquer de l'énergie mais il est
encore plus intéressant d'en fabriquer
une nouvelle matière première et c'est
une réutilisation recyclage une économie
circulaire plus noble il ya plusieurs
manières fabriquer des nations été
léchée la première c'est d incinérer
pour les détruire et tant qu'à faire de
récupérer la chaleur ou schmid et 18 et
de chauffer des logements des bureaux et
ça on le fait depuis longtemps mais il
ya une autre manière de le faire aussi
on peut les offrir ses déchets dans
certains cas où c'est intéressant parce
que une fois aux fruits si le centre
d'enfouissement est bien conçu on
récupère le biogaz et il ya beaucoup
d'endroits dans le monde où avec le
biogaz des décharges et bien on alimente
en gaz naturel des villes et des
industries et ça se fait de plus en plus
on a parlé beaucoup du méthane à la coop
veut 26 à glasgow en disant que le
méthane est un gaz à effet de serre
puissant on à les réhabiliter de
récupérer ce méthane au moins sur les
centres d'enfouissement de déchets donc
on peut faire avec ces déchets interdits
durant et puis on peut faire encore
mieux que d'utiliser des incinérateurs
on peut aller travailler ces déchets non
recyclables et en faire un carburant
qu'on puisse stocker savait que le
problème de l'énergie c'est souvent
qu'on peut pas là ce topic mais ça ne
l'était pas eh bien avec des déchets
avec des déchets non recyclables on peut
faire un carburant spécifique qui est
renouvelable qui de toute façon et
mettrait en se décomposant des gaz à
effet de serre là en l'utilisant en
carburant on économise autant de
d'énergies fossiles qu'on a pas besoin
d'aller chercher dans le sol il ya un
type de décide qu'on n'a pas évoqué qui
est prometteur en matière de recyclage
ce sont les déchets organiques
les feuilles mortes les tontes de
pelouse les décès les restaurants les
résidus de l'industrie agroalimentaire
en faire quoi des engrais biologiques
pour remplacer les engrais chimiques et
on le fait déjà largement mais on va
devoir beaucoup continuer puisque les
engrais chimiques sa pro utilise
beaucoup de gaz de gaz naturel on peut
l'économiser en utilisant des déchets
organiques et puis un jour ces mêmes
déchets organiques au delà même des
fertilisants on va les transformer mais
semble-t-il en protéines pour nourrir le
bétail et ainsi économiser des calories
qui pourrait être réservé aux humains
lorsqu'il faudra nourrir 10 milliards de
personnes on en a bien besoin est les
points d'eau avec moi d'énergie avec
moins de sol si on aime pas déforester
viendra bien besoin vous avez raison et
la transformation écologique vous savez
c'est un enjeu très vaste donc on a
encore beaucoup beaucoup pas inventé bon
voila merci d'arrêter avec nos antoine
frérot donc le pdg de veolia merci
[Musique]